[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
no
así no lleven dame sky y
voy en avión
que me vi que
no me odia
caben en como no soy
yo
una viuda
tantos siglos tantos mundos
tanto espacio
[Aplausos]
gracias por coincidir en este momento
mamá dijo
detrás de esta gran montaña
hay otra vida
otro mundo muy diferente
desde que era niña
recuerdo que mi madre siempre me decía
que yo tenía que salir de mi comunidad
que buscará esta oportunidad
que ella no le tocó
a los 8 años
yo descubrí mi pasión por el canto
por la música
cabe mencionar que mi tierra claudi
toltepec es tierra de músicos
nací entre las nubes
nací entre los pájaros
en este tiempo
en el coro
de la escuela primaria me
escogió mi maestro marcos díaz jiménez
ven
quiero que pase en frente
y cántame una canción
yo canté una canción que es
que canten los niños
ahí es cuando supe que yo me quería
dedicar a cantar
entre la primaria y la secundaria
cantaba en las fiestas patronales de mi
pueblo
en esos concursos que tanto recuerdo que
es lo que único que yo quería
era ganarle a una de mis paisanas
porque gana ahora así que ella se
cantaba muy bien y yo decía ay a mí me
tiemblan todo y yo no canto así como
ella porque ella le hacía se movía
interpretaba y ahí veías a maría reyna
cantar así
pero mi meta
por eso mi meta era
ganar el primer lugar
mi objetivo era
y llegar a ese primer lugar yo siempre
he dicho que
cuando tú quieres algo lo puedes lograr
y para mí el regalo que yo le pudiera
dar a mi madre
eran esos premios que se ganaban porque
eran
útiles de cocina que quizás yo no lo
tenía en mi casa en ese tiempo
gane el tercer lugar
el segundo lugar
hasta que llegue al primer lugar gane
con la canción de selena como la flor
y llega un momento en que
hicimos un grupo musical que se llamaba
marco y sus diez caballeros y la voz de
maría reyna
diez caballeros los diez dedos del
maestro marcos
pero en este momento yo disfruté cantar
en las fiestas en las bodas en los 15
años
a los 15 años es cuando realmente tome
la decisión
de cruzar
la montaña
de irme a guadalajara jalisco
cuando decido migrar a guadalajara
yo no imaginaba el mundo tan diferente
que podría ser de mi comunidad a migrar
a una ciudad tan grande porque para mí
era enorme
llegar en una casa donde yo no conocía
de tres pisos donde la señora me decía a
vas a
trapear y vas a sacudir y también vas a
cocinar
pero fíjense que yo no sabía ni planchar
sabía
ni trapear porque en mi casa solo se va
arriba así de repente nada más
yo dice cómo
y en esas veces que me mucha ropa de
marca
pero no me corrieron que es lo más
importante yo le agradezco a la señora
patricia
pero en ese tiempo tenía
sin mucho
llevaba una semana y yo ya me quería
regresar a mi casa
extrañaba
a mi madre a mi pueblo
pero antes de salir de mi comunidad
yo dije yo no regreso
hasta ser alguien muy importante
y no regrese
llore sí
y muchas veces quise claudicar sí
porque anhelaba estar en un lugar que
era
prácticamente mágico
pero yo tenía un objetivo
qué es lo que mi madre me había dicho
es que yo tenía que buscar mi sueño
en este tiempo
busquen la oportunidad
d
buscar clases de canto
estuve fui al propedéutico de
[Música]
de la vg de guadalajara la escuela de
música de guadalajara
me rechazaron
me dijeron que no podía entrar porque no
sabía asociar no sabía de música pero sí
sabía cantar yo sabía que sabía cantar
pero me dijeron que no
en ese camino
cuando a mí me dijeron que no
entre las calles de guadalajara yo iba
de regreso a mi casa
y que voy viendo
clases de canto
más nunca imaginé que allí estaba la
persona la persona adecuada quien yo
estaba buscando
joaquín garzón mi mentor mi maestro
maestro de canto maestro de vida
y actualmente
mi director musical
cuando él me conoció me dijo de dónde
eres de oaxaca soy de la sierra mixe
orgullosa de yo me sentía orgulloso
decir soy baja caña
me puso a prueba me hizo cantar una
canción que era en ese entonces yo
cantaba puras canciones populares jamás
imaginé cantar la técnica de ópera del
canto yo no sabía nada de eso yo le
canté la canción
no quiero estar sin ti
y el maestro me empieza a acompañar y en
mi tono yo decía como le hizo
en este tiempo también como trabajaba
como empleada doméstica no podía pagar
mis estudios
no podía apagarlos entonces cuando él me
dijo el precio yo le pregunté y maestro
cuánto cuesta la clase
800 pesos al mes era mucho para mí
porque en ese entonces
trabajar en casa me pagaban muy poquito
y todavía tenía que pagar la renta
entonces
le dije muchas gracias
y no volví
no volví
hasta en unos meses más porque yo tenía
la inquietud
de que yo no iba a trabajar nada más
como empleada doméstica sino que
yo fui por un sueño
y ese sueño era cantar
pasan unos meses más
me cambio de trabajo ya ni me acuerdo
cuántas veces me cambié de trabajo pero
me cambié de trabajo
y en otra colonia vuelvo a encontrar
una escuela decía clases de canto
pero lo más
curioso y lo que yo puedo decir es que
yo salí a buscar
y volví a encontrar
a la misma persona
otra escuela del director joaquín garzón
en donde
encontré y ahora sí me quedé
me quedé para poder estudiar lo que yo
quería
en ese tiempo como cantaba puras
canciones populares
el maestro alguna vez me dijo
cántame una canción
pero en tu lengua dando que te escucho
hablar pero no me has cantado en una
canción
en 2012
un poquito antes él me había
pedido esa canción que es especial para
mi madre
como co
[Música]
[Risas]
cómico
o hija
cada sí
[Música]
j
woods modo de anoche
lugar
madre por siempre te llevo en mi corazón
no digas que no estás en mi pensamiento
aunque lejos me encuentre siempre te
llevo conmigo
ese día
descubrí
y pasión el amor
por cantar en mi lengua
por representar a esas mujeres que salen
de sus comunidades a luchar por sus
sueños
hoy por hoy yo les quiero decir
que sigo
cruzando montañas
así como hoy estoy con ustedes y como
dice mi canción
orgullosa soy raíz
qué honor se raíz
de culturas ancestrales
ricas y ceremoniales que desborda este
país
y me siento feliz
porque nací del pueblo sí señor soy del
pueblo y
orgullosa soy rey
[Aplausos]
dios cojo yo